[Musique]
Chantal Hébert Michel coger Dimitri
soudain bonsoir
alors je vous fais d'abord écouter David
Johnston ce matin qui expliquait
pourquoi selon lui une enquête publique
serait
inutile pas nécessaire on écoute
tout simplement Paul niveau de
transparence et d'urgence attendues pour
les Canadiens et les Canadiennes les
renseignements que j'ai examinés sont et
doivent rester ces crèmes
par conséquent tout en quête publique
crédible ne sera pas de tout public
ces renseignements-là plaisaient
donc secret tout en quête publique ne
serait donc pas public ça c'est son
plaidoyer chantage comment avec vous
est-ce que c'est un plaidoyer qui tient
la route
c'est un plaidoyer qui jusqu'à un
certain point se défend puisque on a
toujours compris qu'une enquête publique
deviendrait non public aussitôt qui
serait question de sécurité nationale et
renseignement de sécurité mais en gros
ce que Monsieur Johnson dit sa
proposition c'est
à la lumière de tous les faits auxquels
moi j'ai eu accès donc ceux qui sont
protégés au niveau de la sécurité
nationale
n'importe qui qui les regarde
objectivement arrivera à la même
conclusion que moi et là il propose
quand même un test qui est pas le test
l'enquête publique et dit j'invite deux
comités et les chefs des parties
d'opposition à regarder les mêmes
informations que moi
et à dire si il n'arrive pas à la même
conclusion que moi
et et lui pense que c'est plus loin qui
peut aller qu'une enquête publique ça va
donner beaucoup de gens qui vont dire ce
qu'on a entendu la commission
parlementaire mais c'est à dire pas les
renseignements ou le contexte que lui
apporte et qu'il dit qu'il l'aura appris
en prenant connaissance de tout ça ça
vaut ce que ça vaut à au prochain tour
on reviendra sur si c'était sa meilleure
journée
oui on va revenir plusieurs tours
là-dessus on va prendre le temps de bien
comprendre Michel c'est Auger
ce que Chantal vient dire est important
il dit par contre je poste seul oui je
peux j'étais seul un bout mais il y aura
le comité qui aura accès à tout ce que
j'ai pu vous lire qui m'a convaincu
qu'une enquête publique n'était pas
nécessaire et les chefs d'opposition
venez lire avec moi et ensuite
on jugera est-ce que ça est-ce que ça ça
peut tenir je reprends la mais je prends
la même expression dire la route Michel
jusqu'à un certain point seulement parce
que les chefs de position je trouve la
dimension point 13 vont être ascermentés
pour leur donner la classification top
secrète donc qui peuvent voir toutes les
renseignements secrets du gouvernement
et à partir du moment où ils sont à
fermentés ils sont sujets à leur serment
qui auront prêté de ne pas révéler ces
choses-là alors il y a une espèce de
marché du plat dedans oui ils vont voir
ils vont dire je suis pas d'accord mais
je peux pas vous dire pourquoi ça fait
pas ça fait pas une langue discussion
moi je crois que c'est compliqué d'avoir
une enquête publique dans ces
circonstances là c'est très compliqué
mais ça c'est déjà fait on a vu au
Canada l'enquête McDonald's sur la GRC
des années 70 on a vu la quête câble au
Québec sur des activités de la police
après la crise d'octobre il y avait
plein de documents secrets qu'on a dont
on ne pouvait pas parler il y avait des
moments huit clos il y avait des moments
publics mais ça se fait ok Dimitri
tourne la table là-dessus sur le premier
essentiel aujourd'hui produit de gentils
par pression on va écouter l'opposition
pour pouvoir continuer parce que la joue
de politique est loin d'être terminée
dimétrie
essentiellement on est de retour à la
case de départ c'est-à-dire que c'est le
premier ministre Trudeau qui va trancher
et quand je regarde les deux conférences
de presse d'aujourd'hui celle de
Monsieur Johnson et celle de Justin
Trudeau ma conclusion ses premières mon
Justin Trudeau était beaucoup plus
convaincant que David Johnston surtout
étant donné que la décision finale lui
revient le défi actuel avec les libéraux
puis la recommandation de David Johnston
c'est que je pense que Chatal Chantal en
avait parlé à quelques reprises
l'enquête publique n'était pas la seule
option pour Dave of Johnson il avait
aussi l'option par exemple d'une revue
judiciaire il a essayé essentiellement
choisir aujourd'hui de ne rien faire
parce que toute audience publique menée
par David Johnson les gens ne seront pas
sous serment il n'y aura pas qui que ce
soit qui sera forcé de comparaître donc
sur le plan politique partisan prochaine
élection je pense que cet enjeu demeure
toujours sur la table oui mais est-ce
que la question qu'on lui posait c'était
pas est-ce que oui ou non ils doivent
avoir une enquête publique Dimitri c'est
ça la question lui répond non ça étonne
beaucoup de gens mais répond non il
répond
oui mais l'option il vient
essentiellement puis je conclure
rapidement il vient de redonner la
patate chaude à Justin Trudeau
Chantal ouvrier réagir j'ai vu bouger
ouais deux choses d'abord Michel a
raison sur des enquêtes publiques dont
il a parlé la différence par contre
c'est qu'on parlait d'une autopsie dans
la plupart de ses collègues y compris
Mara et là on parle de quelque chose qui
se passe en temps réel on n'est pas en
train de parler d'un chapitre derrière
nous d'un qu'on a dit sec on est en
train de parler de comment on va se
protéger de quelque chose avec lequel on
vit ça ça rend
l'idée d'une enquête publique moins à
l'échange mais d'autre part monsieur
Johnson selon moi et Dimitri a raison
sur l'histoire de Monsieur Johnson qui
fait des enquêtes publiques des
audiences publiques il se serait aidé
politiquement en recommandant que
quelqu'un d'autre que lui s'occupe de la
suite des choses
très bien on va écouter monsieur Trudeau
qui était content ravi à Monsieur
poignet monsieur signe le monsieur
terrien du Bloc québécois qui était un
pas du tout ravi on écoute
nous accueillons favorablement le
rapport d'aujourd'hui et ses
recommandations
l'ancien gouverneur général a déterminé
que la prochaine étape de son travail
consistera à tenir des audiences
publiques nous soutenons ce travail sans
réserve y compris l'intention du
Gouverneur général de créer un dialogue
avec les Canadiens en particulier ceux
issus des communautés de la diaspora qui
sont souvent la cible de tentative
d'ingérence
à Monsieur Blanchette a déjà un
représentant qui siège sur le comité de
parlementaire qui a exactement ce niveau
de sécurité nécessaire mais encore mieux
on offre à Monsieur Blanchette
directement la capacité d'obtenir le
niveau de sécurité nécessaire pour
qu'ils puissent regarder lui-même
l'intelligence qui est au fondement des
conclusions de ce rapport on sait que
Justin Trudeau a nommé son ami de
famille
sont son ami de ski et son savoir son
voisin du chalet et le membre de la
Fondation troudeau pour camoufler c'est
fait là le Parti conservateur renouvelle
ça revendication de l'enquête publique
qui commence maintenant
je ne suis pas d'accord avec la décision
de Monsieur Johnson je vais dire que je
pense qu'on a besoin d'une enquête
publique et je vais aviser le premier
sucre qu'on va utiliser tous les outils
à notre disposition au niveau fédéral
pour forcer ou pour avancer une enquête
publique
c'est très surprenant très très je
pensais pas que ça serait à ce point pas
indépendant à quel point il a servi le
Premier ministre il a fait du travail
pour le Premier ministre
bon tour de table deux choses
essentielles la crédibilité monsieur de
gentil qui est attaqué assez directement
par les conservateurs et le bloc on
vient de l'entendre et aussi est-ce que
cette demande d'enquête publique va se
répéter pendant un an un an et demi je
vous prochaine direction Chantal sur la
crédibilité de Monsieur Johnson monsieur
Johnson a tenter de se défendre
aujourd'hui en disant je les ai vu
quatre fois quand il était tout petit
que qu'en avez-vous pensé
que c'était un très mauvaise idée de
faire l'histoire de ces sorties de ski à
Mont-Tremblant et des chalets des uns et
des autres mettons que ça faisait pas
très proche de nous
qui n'avons pas de chalet peut-être vous
parce que
ce truc
là alors c'est assez maladroit et ça
montrait que les attaques quand même de
l'opposition en particulier des
conservateurs importants mais je
remarque quand j'écoute les deux qui
parlent
monsieur Trudeau parle toujours de
l'ancien gouverneur général le message
c'est on savait pas que Steven Harper
avait l'habitude de donner des proches
de la famille Trudeau comme gouverneur
général de deux fois plus tôt qu'une et
C poids lièvre
Seigneur sur le messager j'avoue comme
journaliste je suis tellement habitué à
voir ça généralement quand on tire sur
le messager il se passe comment manque
d'arguments sur le fond bon
lieu de s'attaquer constamment monsieur
Johnson qui peuvent faire par ailleurs
dans la reine politique est-ce qu'ils
peuvent répondre sur le fond aux
arguments qu'il est qu'il rend public
sur la non raison d'être ou la raison
d'être d'une enquête Dimitri mais pour
l'instant ce qu'ils disent c'est on doit
le croire c'est à dire monsieur Johnson
on doit le croire sur sa parole et ce
qui est bizarre en même temps c'est que
les députés du Comité de la sécurité
nationale jusqu'à date parce que notre
système n'est pas le même que celui des
Américains n'ont toujours pas vu toutes
les preuves et tous les renseignements
qu'avaient monsieur johnsten écoutez
Patrice à la fin de l'exercice si
Monsieur Trudeau c'est le premier
ministre refuse de déclencher une
enquête publique vous allez trouver la
promesse d'une enquête publique dans les
plateformes électorales du bloc du NPD
et des conservateurs la seule question à
laquelle nous n'avons pas la réponse
est-ce que cet enjeu sera une des
questions de l'urne lors de la prochaine
campagne fédérale il lâcherons pas
visite
il ne lâcheront pas le morceau
l'opposition non absolument pas parce
que ce qu'ils disent qu'est-ce que vous
avez à cacher et c'est un narratif avec
qui monsieur et madame tout le monde se
narratif qui peut raisonner si c'est une
des questions de l'urne donc Michel
l'offre l'offre au chef de des
oppositions de venir et de lire tout ce
que Johnson a lu de l'école le comité
lise tout ça l'offre sera refusée je
comprends bien Michel c'est je pense que
oui parce que comme je disais tout à
l'heure s'ils sont assez remontés ça
c'est la première des choses la deuxième
les parties de position aurait une bien
plus grande crédibilité s'ils avaient
fait leur demande d'enquête publique en
attaquant pas la personne de Monsieur
Johnson qui doit quelque chose à
quelqu'un de ce qu'il doit ses amis de
ski ou à la personne qui l'a nommée un
gouvernement général qui est Monsieur
pour la suite des choses monsieur
Johnson aurait dû se récuser aurait dû
dire bon ma personnalité semble causer
problème parfait nommer quelqu'un
d'autre il y a pas de problème mais à
cause de ça
va devenir ça va pas arrêter jusqu'au
prochaines élection dernier tour de
table là-dessus monsieur Johnson insiste
beaucoup sur le côté
le côté
dangereux de ces de ces ligues de ces
parce que je vais le dire en français de
ces fuites merci de ces fuites dans les
journaux dans globalement de ces
rapports de ces demi rapport et il dit
c'est pas bien
Katsuya tout à l'heure disait il
s'attaque aux journaux moi j'ai plutôt
compris que c'était aux gens qui avaient
fuité en disant vous moi j'ai pu lire
l'ensemble de ces problèmes-là et le
public n'a pas eu le contexte et il y a
eu des erreurs donc qui ont été commis
Chantal qu'est-ce que vous retenez de de
ça
que ce serait intéressant ou que ça va
être intéressant parce que moi je pense
qu'il y a des parties de position qui
vont prendre connaissance de cette
annexe parce qu'à un moment donné on
peut pas se promener en disant je veux
pas le savoir
c'est pas une position défendable en
politique publique de dire je pense que
je sais je pourrais le savoir mais je
veux pas
et avec l'option de dire ce que moi j'ai
lu ça correspond pas du tout à ce que
Johnson pense il était vraiment
complètement biaisé c'est quand même une
option là c'est pas dévoiler un secret
il y a une critique à l'égard des médium
mais en gros ce que ça dit c'est le
contexte c'est important et ce que vous
avez vu c'est juste un morceau on vous a
dit que c'était un morceau du lac moi je
vous dis ça aurait pu être un morceau du
ciel
et le portrait complet est important et
il réfute
à ce niveau là il refuse certains des
reportages qu'il a vu mais c'est un fait
que tout le monde comprend que ce genre
de fuite c'est des renseignements
partiels c'était ça l'intérêt d'une
enquête publique pour voir le portrait
au sens large c'est ça et lui le vu et
nous ne l'avons pas vu ce portrait au
sens large et par exemple l'affaire and
dog le député libéral qui s'est
soustrait Dimitri du caucus libéral
global l'avait accusé d'avoir insinué au
consuls chinois mais attendez donc pour
libérer les deux mycos c'est une
histoire un peu à bracadabra
lui dit moi j'ai tout vu que c'est faux
il dit pas c'est peut-être faux voici un
exemple de toutes ces informations qui
proviennent du CRS il faut prendre avec
des pincettes non
sur l'affaire de Monsieur Dang j'ai
jamais vraiment pris au sérieux parce
que apparemment monsieur dorgne est
accusé d'avoir dit au consul chinois de
ne pas libérer les deux maiko parce que
c'est les conservateurs qui en
profiteraient donc c'est un très mauvais
conseil c'est le gouvernement en place
qui a profité si un profit attiré sur la
libération de deux Canadiens ce que je
peux dire puis Chantal vous avez raison
mais j'ai trouvé les commentaires de
Monsieur johnsteen un peu provocateur
donc ceux qui sont responsables pour les
fuites
ils vont continuer à envoyer des mémos
secrets pour faire valoir leurs points
donc encore une fois une raison de plus
pourquoi aujourd'hui ou demain n'est pas
le dernier le dernier chapitre de cette
histoire mais le cube Rubik's dans cette
discussion c'est que Michel pour faire
la lumière sur cette histoire et toutes
les autres encore faut-il qu'on puisse
étaler dans une enquête publique au
grand jour certaines choses on sait
qu'on ne peut pas avec ce genre
d'information là alors on fait quoi
Michel C
on peut pas tout étaler mais je pense
que le public comprend très bien qu'on
ne peut pas tout étaler et qu'on peut
faire une enquête publique quand même en
donnant des éléments de contexte en
expissant ça bien comme vous c'est plus
compliqué c'est plus compliqué mais ça
se fait ça c'est déjà fait et dans la
situation actuelle je pense encore la
meilleure solution
ok très bien alors si je vous comprends
bien les trois pires différents avec
différents accents cette histoire là
c'est très loin d'être le point d'orgue
puis la fin aujourd'hui Chantal
parce que s'il y avait eu une enquête
publique là on rentre dans le débat de
qui décide qui fait quoi
terme de référence mais j'avoue que
j'étais totalement convaincu sur la
pertinence d'enquête publique alors ce
que j'ai vu
m'a conforté dans mon impression que
c'était pas le meilleur véhicule mais il
y en avait d'autres et en tout c'était
le laisser de côté c'est ça comme vous
dites la suite il y aurait pu avoir
vous Dimitri vous aussi j'aurais pu
avoir un nom mais
c'est ça
Legault aujourd'hui on va écouter un
petit cours extrait vous riez déjà
Dimitri court exprès mais il y a rien de
qui nous amène très très loin mais ça
donne l'atmosphère quand même
il y a deux sujets que je veux traiter
avec lui d'abord la filière batterie il
y a des investissements qui vont se
décider dans les prochains mois les
prochaines années donc c'est important
que les partis politiques au fédérales
comprennent que c'est stratégiques pour
le Québec la filière batterie le
deuxième sujet que je vais aborder avec
Monsieur poignet c'est l'immigration la
place du français au Québec on le sait
la CAQ demande de rapatrier des pouvoirs
matières d'immigration
je vous félicite d'avoir coupé réduire
des impôts parce qu'il nous faut le même
chose au niveau fédéral les gens
travaillent travaillent travaillent mais
ça paye pas donc il faut continuer de
réduire des impôts et des éliminer les
taxes supplémentaires pour rendre la vie
abordable 700 microvités principales
d'assurer l'amener du français au Québec
je sais que c'est quelque chose qui vous
touche personnellement
bon ben tout va bien Dimitri on est loin
évidemment d'une campagne c'est pas
demain matin on se souvient que Monsieur
Lebeau avait demandé au Québécois de
voter Renaud tout le pour ne pas voter
pour des parties centralisateurs comment
vous voyez cette mouvance les deux
Dimitri
premièrement puis peut-être ça ne paraît
pas mais monsieur pollièvre a choisi une
approche très différente de ces
prédécesseurs c'est-à-dire que il ne va
pas miser sur les appuis de parti
politique provinciaux puis vous avez
mentionné Patrice le fait que monsieur
Legault a fait sa recommandation lors de
la dernière campagne fédérale mais les
Québécois ne l'ont pas écouté ils ont
voté majoritairement pour des députés
libéraux fédéraux et bloquistes donc
monsieur pollière se dit si on va faire
une percée au Québec ça va être grâce à
nous je suis un peu surpris que ça a
pris si longtemps avant de rencontrer le
premier le premier indice du Québec même
si sa stratégie ne passe pas par le même
canal que c'est pré décesseurs
c'est-à-dire on espère avoir l'appui de
la CAQ pour faire une percée au Québec
Michel sait comment vous voyez la suite
je pense que Monsieur Lebeau était pas
pressé de rencontrer Monsieur polliath
non plus ce qui explique que ça a pris
du temps je pense qu'il voit aussi la
réaction que les Québécois ont dans
l'opinion publique par rapport à
Monsieur poignet pas sûr que je vais me
coller à ça moi et parfois les
exagérations verbales de Monsieur
poignet ne le servent pas alors
rentrer là en disant ça faut ajuster un
Trudeau c'est le troisième meilleur pas
été bâti un moment donné
alors
on n'a pas senti d'atomes crochus d'une
personnellement puis d'autres parts je
posture que monsieur Legault pourrait
refaire le même le même rappel en disant
il y a deux quand tu sens réalisateurs
il y en a un qui le dépôt je pense qu'on
va aller ailleurs
parce que du côté du côté pragmatique
des choses les avec Monsieur Trudeau
monsieur Legault depuis quelques temps
on a pu régler quelques quelques
dossiers Chantal
bon d'abord toujours une mauvaise idée
de venir dire pour le Premier ministre
Québec pourquoi il a décidé d'abandonner
une promesse c'est il y a jamais
personne à la carte qui a dit que
c'était la faute de Justin Trudeau alors
quand on vient en visite là on dit pas
si c'est mal peinturer parce que cette
boisson
ça commence mal mais l'autre problème de
de Pierre Poilly à au Québec c'est que
François Legault voit bien en même temps
se rapprochement entre le Bloc québécois
et le PQ et là est-ce qu'il y a vraiment
le goût de jouer dans ce film là de dire
votez pas pour Justin Trudeau quand
votez pas pour Justin Trudeau ça peut
vouloir dire aussi voter pour le bloc
alors moi j'ai l'impression qu'au
prochaines élections la CAQ va faire et
monsieur Legault comme son ami Monsieur
Ford en Ontario c'est ensemble
ça va être différent un peu que la
dernière fois
Paul Saint-Pierre plat Mondon qui
étonne aussi on a été étonné ce matin
que moi j'ai été étonné ce matin par le
rapporteur et là il veut qu'on
déclassifie les secrets de 95 la des
archives la commission grenier on écoute
Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon et on
revient
que l'on soit fédéraliste ou
indépendantiste ou qu'on soit les deux
il y a un principe plus fondamental de
transparence envers la population et de
respect de notre démocratie si un des
moments démocratiques les plus
importants de notre histoire a été le
théâtre de plusieurs fraudes électorales
faut absolument que l'information soit
divulguée de manière transparente
Michel si Auger archives grenier qui
sont pour l'éternité secrète est-ce que
c'est possible c'est une opération
possible
le Parlement peut tout faire sur changer
un homme en femme dit on s'imagine qu'il
y a quelque chose de possible si on
passait une loi en même temps
c'est étrange que le juge grenier après
ça il dit ça c'est fermé pour toujours
et jamais ça ne verront le rayon de
soleil là alors probablement qu'il va
avoir de la pluie de Monsieur le bois
déjà dit d'ailleurs qui voulait que ça
sorte ses documents là cela dit la ce
que Monsieur
de ramener les pékistes qui regardent la
carte qui ont voté
avant au bercail et une des bonnes
façons c'est toujours de dire on s'est
fait voler le référendum il va avoir une
grosse surprise parce que si jamais il a
les documents il va se rendre compte que
juge grenier avait un mandat extrêmement
limité pas de parler de des gens qui ont
voté légalement pas de faire ci pas de
faire ça sur Option Canada et il a été
capable de trouver des dépenses
excédentaires d'à peu près une demi
million pour 5 millions comme on avait
dit dans le lit de maman de faire alors
bon il y a eu des problèmes
constitutionnels là-dedans le fédéral de
projet de la commission mais je pense
que ça va être spectaculaire petit mot
très petit Chantal et Dimitri Chantal
si j'étais le gouvernement de gauche
m'arrangerait pour que ce soit public
parce que les choses qui sont publiques
sont toujours moins intéressantes que
les choses qui semblent cachées on
boucle la boucle le premier sujet
Dimitri
conclusion rapide depuis depuis le mois
d'octobre honnêtement chapeau au
stratège en communication pour Monsieur
Paul Saint-Pierre flamandon malgré le
fait qu'il a deux députés et lui trois
l'Assemblée nationale il domine la
couverture médiatique sur un paquet de
sujets merci Chantal Michel Dimitri à
très bientôt au revoir bonne soirée au
revoir